hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
we're talking about tablets today a lot
of great tablets were announced and
produced this year and it's been a great
year for the evolution of tablets and
the different form factors were able to
see now and actually get tablet skin so
without any further ado we're gonna go
ahead and take a look one by one at the
best tablets for 2012 and the ones
you're gonna want to keep an eye on for
this holiday season so I'm gonna kick it
off with the Nexus 10 the Nexus 10 is my
personal favorite tablet right now and
there are two main things that help it
stand out from actually every other
tablet out there on the market next to
the Nexus 7 first of all this guy has a
2560 by 1600 Super HD display it has a
pixel density of right around 300 pixels
per inch
it is extremely high resolution text
looks very sharp images appear great
color reproduction is awesome viewing
angles are great it is just an overall
excellent display and it's probably the
best display on any tablet out there
right now the second thing that kind of
separates it from the rest is the fact
that it's running Android 4.2 jelly bean
I say kind of because there's also the
Nexus 7 but it's running a pure stock
version of Android 4.2 so you get all
the great features you get photosphere
you get the new camera you get the new
notification panel all that awesome
stuff and that's what really separates
it from the other tablets out there it's
one of my favorites it's a very fast
tablet app support is getting up there
with tablets of this high resolution but
I think in a couple months when all the
apps are updated and what this has a
huge ecosystem to go with it it's gonna
be a hell of an option hey guys
johnathan here from the TLD today
Channel and I gotta admit I almost feel
like I'm walking into a trap talking
about the iPad on the mkbhd channel I
know a lot of you guys are Android fans
but we're here to focus on why each
tablet will make a good gift and while I
fill both the Nexus 10 and the iPad are
hands-down the best tablet options on
the market just in case you're not sold
with the Nexus 10 or maybe you're
heavily into the Apple ecosystem the
iPad actually has a few advantages over
the Nexus 10
starting with optimized apps obviously
the Nexus 10 has a higher screen
resolution a higher pixel density but
all that means nothing unless you have
the apps that are optimized to take
advantage of all those pixels the Nexus
10 does have quite a bit of optimized
apps but the iPad is second to none and
takes the cake in that category not only
in the
number of optimized apps but that in
combination with the best tablet GP on
the market you're gonna get the best
gaming experience out of a tablet on the
iPad so just in terms of app loading
times smoothness frame rates and overall
just the quantity and selection of apps
that's where the iPad is second-to-none
it also features a slightly bigger
storage capacity the Nexus 10 coming in
at 64 gigs max and you also have the
option to get ultra fast lightening LTE
so the only downside to the iPad is
obviously the Apple premium they start
at $4.99 and go all the way up to 829
depending on your configuration and if
you choose to get a data equipped iPad
hey Lamarr Wilson here and I'm in love
with the iPad Mini and think it would be
a great gift for the holidays when I was
at the Apple store the seven inch form
factor just blew me away completely not
just fell in love now starting at 3:29
are they cheaper tablets out there well
absolutely but they're also cheaper cars
out there yet people still going by the
BMW this is an excellent build quality
he is consistently fast and there are so
many apps that are actually optimized
for the tablet doesn't matter if you
have the large iPad or the smaller iPad
everything looks great and that really
is an important part because in the end
it's all about the user experience
especially with someone who was not
geeky or techie who just beats a device
that's gonna work so if you're a person
who loves Apple or you a person who is
interested in it first time I gotta say
this is a good gateway drug but don't do
drugs but but if you do this is the
gateway this is the start of forming a
habit and some drugs and with just
buying more Apple products but but
you'll be happy not very rich but you
you'll have some money left I don't I
don't know I just love it but I don't
eat what's up guys Lou here and my pick
for a tablet this holiday season is this
right here this is the Nexus 7 from
Google and a soos and the reason it's my
pick is well there's a number of reasons
actually the main one though is the
price point you can get into this tablet
for a hundred and ninety-nine bucks
that's the starting point
and it's easily the most aggressive
starting point in the entire roundup
that we're talking about the main
competitors in the tablet space another
thing I like about it is form factor the
aspect ratio on the screen means that
you can wrap one hand around it and
utilize it that way whether you're
reading on the subway the ball
anything like that you get a really
comfortable grip with one hand and I
think that's sort of where it beats the
iPad Mini the iPad maybe having a
slightly more square form factor means
that it's a little uncomfortable to hold
in one hand in this same fashion right
here
you've also got a relatively high
resolution display and and another
really important feature is the fact
that you've got the vanilla Android
experience what that means is there's no
manufacturer skin on top of here bogging
it down and it also means you're going
to get updates pushed out to the device
as soon as they are available so a great
pic this holiday season the Nexus 7 from
Google and a Susan what's up guys
Armando here showing you why I believe
the Microsoft Surface tablet is a great
gift for the holidays the surface tablet
is one of the best-built tablets of 2012
it features a magnesium body stereo
speakers and ports like a micro HDMI
full size USB and expandable storage
using a micro SD card a big plus is the
integrated kickstand and the option to
buy a touch or type keyboard that
enhances your experience while also
protecting your tablet on the go the
surface has one of the most impressive
web browsers in the market today
Internet Explorer is buttery smooth
website rendering is very fast and it
also has flash support the surface is
running on Microsoft Windows 8 RT and
starts at $4.99 for a 32 gigabyte model
however you only get about 16 gigabytes
of free storage since the operating
system takes up half if you can live
with that and the lack of app support I
highly recommend this premium tablet and
you won't be disappointed so there you
go guys those are just a few of the
awesome tablets that are available to
you this holiday season of course there
are some tablets that we didn't mention
on the list there is the iPad 3 that you
could like there is the Kindle Fire HD
there is the Galaxy Note 10.1 there is
the Asus Transformer Pad Infinity there
are a lot more great tablets but those
are sort of our top picks for now but
ultimately they pick for number one is
up to you so let us know what your
number one pick is in the comment
section below also below in the
description below the like button on
this video are the links to all the
awesome channels that contributed to
this video definitely check those out
these guys
make awesome videos on their own channel
so you're gonna want to watch those and
get a kick out of those as well so
either way there's been mkbhd hope you
enjoy the video hope you learned
something today thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more videos like this
to come thanks guys
talk to you later
you